David Spade is mourning the loss of his  sister-in-law fashion designer Kate  Spade the comedian posted this image to  Instagram taking family photos together  at Christmas he captioned the pic quote  we had so much fun that day she was so  sharp and quick on her feet she could  make me laugh so hard I still can't  believe it  David also shared this memory with Kate  at one of his book signings  he wrote quote I love this pic of her so  pretty I don't think everyone knew how  effing funny she was it's a rough world  out there people  the NYPD confirmed to et Tuesday morning  that the 55 year old fashion icon was  found dead in her Manhattan apartment  the cause of death was an apparent  suicide Kate is survived by her husband  Andy Spade David's brother  and their teenage daughter Frances  Beatrix  [Music]  you